so this happened to someone i know what
they got banned from twitch
the platform yeah for saying that they
think it's
not fair
for trans women to be competing in
women's sports okay they got
de-platformed yeah and i thought it was
so fascinating
because i watched the debate where it
happened
i watched the debate where it happened i
want you to watch some of the things
that the other people who didn't get
banned said the trans athlete is going
to do a lot to like foster a lot of
really bad will against like trans
people in general i think it's a really
good turf argument for well look these
people just want to destroy women's
spaces who gives a [ __ ] if women can't
compete at the top level
sounds completely reasonable to me and
if it eliminates uh women's spaces from
sports
and makes it so that
i mean keep in mind it'd be eliminating
men's spaces from sports as well and i
have absolutely no issue with that um
the turfs are completely right i do want
to actually get rid of gendered spaces
uh in the sports arena and that they are
100 right and i don't base my opinions
off of what the most radical turfs you
know fear that i'm going to do
the [ __ ] did you say
honestly this whole thing was uh kind of
crazy
these people were really sitting up here
talking about it's perfectly acceptable
to eliminate women's spaces they know it
eliminates women's spaces and they're
for that
they're not even like there's a trans
trans man that was saying that
they don't even cave no
they're like yo whatever space that
females were supposed to have we don't
care get rid of them that's them and
even if trans women specifically uh
because they are in like the starting
process of their transition or whatever
have significant competitive advantages
let's say they do in 99 of the
businesses they don't there's plenty of
empirical evidence to suggest that they
don't but even if they do it does not
matter it does not matter because it's
not unnatural
it's not unnatural to be trans
doc
it's not unnatural to be trans unless
you think it's unnatural to be trans in
which case you are transphobic that's it
that's the take
hormone therapy all this stuff all of
it's very natural you know taking uh
puberty blockers or like like hormone
blockers taking all this stuff perfectly
natural none of these folks get you get
banned well someone says hey this thing
is unethical it's not fair it's not
right you get banned
it's fascinating to watch from the
outside looking in because you realize
how disconnected the online world is
from reality you ask most people reality
they're like yeah that's just not right
yeah i see people who live in like
little lefty bubbles and they're [ __ ]
online platforms on twitter and some
[ __ ] like that and they're gonna be
convinced that this [ __ ] makes sense
there's a reason why most of the public
is completely against it but these
people
they live in cuckoo land they make no
sense
he really said that transitioning is
natural it's not i'm not saying that
this gender is four is not natural
that's not what we talk about
transitioning is nothing natural it's
like saying that things taking steroids
is natural
it's not that's what transmitters
wanting to be
wanting to be big
i mean
it's there it's a feeling that you have
it's there it's there valid as [ __ ]
real thing
but
that's not that's not the definition of
what natural is you know some dude uh
i think his name is derek he does this
channel called more plates more dates
basically talks about like people's
cycles what they use how they get bigger
he doesn't understand yeah yeah so he's
breaking this down yeah and he was
explaining that leah thomas when she had
to transition for like the 12 months
beforehand yeah the levels that she had
to reach for her test levels okay
like the milliliters that she had to
reach
were like six times higher than what the
average cis woman has to reach
meaning
even when she meets the threshold that
the governing body set up it literally
makes no sense because it's still six
times higher than what women have to do
and even the testing thing you know how
you solder for
ufc it's like super strict they come
watch through the whole process with
this one it's loosey-goosey so you can
cheat it super easily there is very
little oversight when it comes to it he
was exploiting the whole thing because
he breaks it down he brings down the
like the milliliters he understands the
signs and i was just like [ __ ]
i thought this [ __ ] was my signs it's
not you know how long they have to do
the whole like um
bringing down their hormone levels
12 months
that means they trade their entire lives
their teenage puberty all that stuff one
gender get all the benefits the recovery
of testosterone all this stuff being a
male
and then they transitioned
kept they don't have to remove the
surgery meaning their testes are still
producing do you understand
and they think this shit's equal
i don't know
i learned some stuff like in terms of
like the actual technical breakdown that
really fascinated me because i was like
it's like that
this subject is really getting to you
what you mean oh we've been talking
about this though to me to me it's not
even about the whole sports thing now
it's like about everything else
surrounding it you get what i'm saying
it's like
[ __ ] are getting banned for
just signatures yes so now it's just
like
it's another leg yeah you get what i'm
saying
lung capacity is actually mostly related
to height and like ashley said earlier
is only really important for super high
endurance sports no hold on when it
comes to lung capacity and bone density
it's not
unless you're talking about super
endurance uh sports it's nev it's never
going to be the limiting factor what
about height what about you can have
tall women what about height what about
you can have tall women
when i watch these people saying
they want to eliminate female spaces
they want to
um
they want to um
they don't care
if they take the spot of somebody if you
were 17th will [ __ ] you then because you
weren't even good enough to make the top
16 to make it to the meet so for trans
women
it just fascinates me how quickly like
the cause went from being supporting
women to [ __ ] women
you know what i'm saying
like i remember for the last like five
six years everything was about women's
issues
right and like basically like females
and then trans women came over and now
it's just about trans women exclusively
and like female issues don't even matter
anymore so basically
it comes down to this if you're
fortrans right you're misogynistic
and it always circles back to the same
thing it's like you're always a
transphobe
always always always always you're like
hey guys the science doesn't really
matter what you guys say transphobia if
you question your transform
like i was watching people get compared
to like to like
them hitler type dudes
for saying some of this stuff i'm like
really yo like example because yo
what will smith did was wrong
he says
what chris
chris rock did was wrong
just
they're just using the words to shut it
all down just to shut it down [ __ ] and
you know
with racism we've been through that so
that's why i'm not phased
yeah it's going to calm down they'll
come around or not yeah
i'll link the debate in the
in the link in the description below so
you guys can go watch how crazy it is
and how like delusional some of these
people are they are just making [ __ ] up
at one point one of them brings them up
they go like yeah these are all the
someone's like all right well listen if
you feel this way we're all the trans
men who are killing it since you feel
like there's no difference in you can
why aren't the trans man like competing
on this level and then you know she did
she brings up mac bags who's a wrestler
who's competing against um who's
competing and winning
so i'm like word cool let me google this
it's magbegs
is a female born female
who's transitioning competing against
women
and taking testosterone macbeth is like
78-0 so basically she's taking stewards
right
euless trinity wrestler mac bags is a
champion once again today in a dramatic
finish the transgender athlete defended
his state title it has been a long and
controversial road for the senior as
news 8's matt howerton shows us he's now
focused on college and closing this
chapter for good
[Applause]
when their hands were raised
students who won state wrestling titles
were met with thunderous applause
except for macbeth's i don't care
that
that match i gave my all that match
you put me in front of anybody i will
arrest you
begs a transgender wrestler from euless
trinity closed out his high school
career saturday with a second straight
state title in the final seconds of his
match he avoided a possible pinfall to
win by decision
and people booed his success every time
like i look through comments or people
are saying the same thing they're
they're saying steroids i mean it just
comes down to technique and who has the
most heart last year a parent went to
court to keep begs from wrestling in the
female division if you didn't know begs
is transitioning from a girl to a boy
and takes testosterone but it isn't
against the rules because it's
sanctioned by a doctor
and uil policy says begs must wrestle
girls because that's what his birth
certificate says he is
it's a controversy begs will leave
behind when he heads to college he's
hoping to wrestle out of state on a
scholarship and the ncaa will let him
compete with men
but he's also dreaming for something
bigger my focus is now to go not just
ncaa but go the olympics train for the
olympics 2020 and 2024. parents told us
begg should have been wrestling boys all
along or not wrestling at all uil
officials have said publicly that they
never got an official request from begs
or his school to wrestle boys bex's
family contests it wouldn't have
mattered and wants the state to take a
fresh look at the rules i wanted to come
out on something and i'm always
in my heart i feel i am a champion if
anything all this teen wants is for
students to be honored for what they've
done
and not judged by who they are
amen i'm gonna just leave you guys on
this final note and then because priest
is already gone female spaces have an
important place i think trans women also
need to be protected in their own right
but the way that you guys are going
about destroying women's spaces just
like don't give a [ __ ] i think it's very
very telling and i think if females feel
some type of way and they really feel
strongly you guys should do it for us
it's just a video topic for you guys
it's your space so i'll recommend you
guys to get up in arms about it because
at the end of the day mean preacher
never going to be as emotionally
involved i'm just looking at it on the
outside like these [ __ ] is
crazy for you guys it's a larger issue
so that's all i'm going to say on the
topic good